une française plaisir aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur rhône auction parce que ça
fait un bail qu'on n'est pas passé sur
ce jeu et honnêtement je l adore on va
pouvoir encore mais des petits coups
comme ça sur les gens qui qui double le
mal qu'ils font des queues de poisson
qui nous font des doigts même en passant
sur leurs motos voilà moi je n'accepte
pas ça mais je sais qu'ils acceptaient
pas non plus ce qui est normal car si on
accepte ça on fait quoi
c'est parti je me suis jamais plié
touche attendait le premier honneur à ma
tâche peut attraper remet qu'attendu je
t'attrape au regard des bons gars
regardez regardez regardez attendait
regardez ça est drôle oui eh bien la
voilà j'ai pas trop d'amis communs sur
des amis de manière efficace voilà à
bientôt le poteau voilà bien sûr c'est
génial ah ben voilà que voter j'ai même
pas qui a fait ça mais si j'avais su
voilà en ce moment j'ai pas trop d'amis
opus donc c'est parfait alors quand ce
avec quoi un user ou un seul est jammer
d'accord j'ai crié un fait exprès c'est
trop tard j'ai su plaire aux [ __ ] sur
les toits c'est tendu mais attendez du
coup qui peut attraper quelqu'un comme
ça et là je le lâche et je le rattrape
voilà ça sert à rien tu apprends galère
viens là haut un temps il car ou pas ça
te revoilà vatan c'est bon il est bien
mort et bien et c'est pourquoi
voilà voilà ces médias violents aux
plats exquis mon gars et là vouloir nous
doublent études et gâche mais c'est
comme ça que ça marche put un battant
aulas a bientôt arriver en italie
d'arrivée la part de tous côtés
je joue ma ni [ __ ] 1 à l'aller et la
raccourci bon gars désolé oui [ __ ]
j'ai bien cru qu'on allait mourir
on est premier ou le deuxième est le
premier c'est pas toi pas tout excuse
moi pardon à raymond couderc au diable
lui gâcher notre joueur tu nous laisses
être heureux s'il te plait a même dit
que j'suis mort il me dit que j'ai
raison janot complet nofollow pas live à
la halle aux toiles taux d orly barrel à
antony ce quelqu'un me prendre l'avion
sa seule phrase d'espagnol que je le
sais dire mais rien et il ya un peu
comme à 0.6 à hill hd bombe l'ebit h on
sent pas au cholestérol au melia un bug
j'ai put j'ai dû ce prix doit dire
limité bon on va pas se plaindre déjà
déjà 47 lui même alors on n'a pas tort
mon gars oh attention quoi et pourquoi
on va partager on est là pour s'amuser
pour tous défoncés à ça m'a fait du bien
que j'ai pas d'amis s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais avoir un ami par exemple toi
tu es là haut up était à moi voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe
attention le procès sur mon avis via la
voilà ben voilà on résiste mieux à deux
pour toi l'arbre voilà des 7e le plus
fantastique assez comme ça va vite ça
l'est beaucoup moins et aux eaux la
danse au viala au plat mais je voulais
je me suis rattrapé si tu es le seul mec
qui voulait bien être au baby [ __ ]
déjà fuck the police
by claude il est mort je voulais dire à
isle of the police voilà et nous avec
deux poteaux in your own aux noms il
passe à travers
voilà ok ballon meurt à 2 finalement
elle n'y croyait pas on n'y croyait plus
la fausse manip dur à rattraper
oh [ __ ] vous voyez bien vous le voyez
encore à auge adore ce genre de boxe est
très mignon très doux j'ai un grappin je
m'en foutais
on lâche on est un petit olala mais
regardez là on est par exemple quoi amer
défaut face detec d'art moi je m'étais
carrément enflammé par exemple comme ça
nul
oui on va dire que la barbade avec
l'avant n'a pas le temps je suis un
samouraï sur ma moto en bordel samura
était temps modernes bien là hop là bas
non madame mais là venez là mais [ __ ]
mais un million mais aujourd'hui pour
tient mais craque vers lui et bon os
voilà j'ai mis un petit coup de poêle
pas du tout c'est quoi c'est une rame
c'est pareil on peut faire un steak en
faisant cuire sur la toile je suis
désolé 20h toi mais oui [ __ ] il
contredit qui sait qu'avec un livre de
cuisine c'est toi et ben vas tu vas te
faire mais [ __ ] mais mais je vais le
député attend le mec est en train de
phase i contre regarder il fasse contre
un poteau mais faut l'aider cet homme au
crâne chauve la ola là mais ça ça c'est
digne d'un mec je sais pas - ghost rider
et là tu as cru que c'était fini pour
moi
eh ben tu as tort en de la prime et
gâchait je vais en mission je ma fille
dans l'appartement de madame de duval
sait pas qui est cette femme
mais sur les choux et madame duval est
en vie j'ai eu un mec j'ai eu un bon on
a en 2d pour s'en faire deux ça va
passer je vous jure c'est à passer c'est
pour vous 4 0
je préfère mourir non au juste manon ma
voilà le menu qui me qui m'agresse comme
ça mais on était au milieu de quinze
mecs même même en faisant ça on en tue
les deux mois c'était sûr dégage mais
j'aime la police va manquer est ok c'est
pour toi
abate mort avant raconté on va pas le
temps
ah bah franchement là où pouvait pas
faire plus vite je paye ma contravention
en c4 à bientôt au prince et 4 à bientôt
j'aime bien j'adore ce sont les voitures
je peux la c4 et non on peut rien faire
elles ont le pouvoir c'est une dictature
de la part des voitures
bonjour à bientôt patrick mc ternes en
bas tu vas terme nantais dans les
tournants c'était faible c'est très
faible voilà mais j'écris de la poésie
en ce moment finalement une longue épée
oh oui excalibur je veux qu'elle
s'appelle excalibur jeu voir si c'est
vraiment une longue année puisque sinon
il ya scandale au scandale merde c'est
bon we hope la merde c'est pas bon
ménage mais [ __ ] de bec
jme facebook qui part pour kouassi alors
là si vous me dites que c'était parce
qu'il est bas je sors ma grande épée et
je m'approche du joueur 6 lorsque
soudainement europe
il a plus de têtes à vous ai pas dit que
j'appelle ce qu'il est bien il est mort
quand même voilà ya plus deux premiers
il ya un primeur éventuellement au point
la rue à gauche qui vendait des fruits
légumes c'était nul à chier
tiens c'est un responsable est tout
aussi ça me paie les guenot ces
sympathiques
allez hop us la suite à perdre et là il
ya plein de gens je vais lips voilà il
sait lips est aussi bien des remous
picchu blanc wever en arrière et aucun
problème regarder au plat là en tant que
l'hélico autant tellico ça passe à
travers nos médias renâclent à j'ai
gâché toutes mes balles ça passe à
travers tout cas c'est pas qui prendra
jacques ménard surtout qu'on attendait
dans mes jeux j'ai exposé dix mille
voitures j'ai qu'une demi étoile quoi
love symbol j'étais à lèvres fxf de chez
moi pour marquer mais regardez quoi awa
géant et enfin une demi étoile après
avoir tué 622 mec au se font défoncer
voilà comme ça c'est là que vous
toucherez était tout l'été j'ai au stick
à boualem hamadache désarroi de cette
vidéo sur moi dans mon chat ça m'a fait
du bien de faire un petit troisième opus
maintenant on peut se faire des amis
comme si on les attrape ont fait ça ça
fait vraiment plaisir
j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas et les vidéos comme
d'habitude à arette je veux pas être
tournamy bras arrête beau courage à ceux
qui ont passé leurs partiels bahdja
s'ils les ont déjà passé bas je peux
plus dire bon courage
bon c'est con ce que je dis à mon sens
trop termine dans une nouvelle vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé tient tout bis
m
[Applaudissements]